like this film in a world is set in the
egotistical world of voiceovers what was
the inspiration of that we met a few
egos in the voice-over world I think I
you know I've met a bunch of egos in a
myriad of different instance you know
industries so I think you know I never
like to think of the movie as just a
voiceover movie because at the end of
the day it is about interpersonal
relationships and about the neuroses
that we deal with when we have
insecurities about succeeding in any
metier you know so I think you know I
hope that it is relatable in that way
because I'm not you know a star
voice-over artist and I felt very
connected to this story I did love the
idea of the voice-over industry being
this umbrella to tell the story because
it does offer a cacophony of really
hilarious personalities and characters
and sounds and and so I think I was
attracted to that aspect of it and I
just happened to be obsessed with voice
so and your character obviously like
yourself as a real facility for accents
and imitation I think that when did you
realize yourself that you had that
facility I mean ever since I was a
little girl I have been doing voices I
was a precocious annoying aspiring
actress when I was little girl where you
know my mom was very soft-spoken and she
just thought where did you come from
you're an alien because I would console
to people just as a small person and
just be like I just tried to imitate
them or mimic that I mean it was you
know just socially not I would try to be
nice about it but I was just obsessed
with accents and to the point where you
know when you travel as an unaccompanied
minor my parents were divorced and lived
in different states and I would I would
go every other weekend on the plane to
New York and I would get buddy-buddy
with the stewardesses at like 13 so that
I could get or even like 11 so I could
do the security announcement like they
would let me do it because it was a cool
voice or like I could pretend to be
someone else like a big fancy adult or
something so I'd be like hi and welcome
to Atlanta service - seven six - no
so I was even doing that then so what is
your favorite voice of all time if you
could do any just one voice what would
it be I think my favorite dialect is
probably like southeast London I went to
college here so I have an affection for
genomic know I talk a lot I like that a
lot but then I would say that the most
beautiful voice that ever lived was Don
LaFontaine who has since passed passed
away and he was he is a main reason why
I wanted to dedicate this movie to him
in a way now you mentioned there's so
many big personalities and characters in
the film aren't they and Ken Marino
plays one in particular and you have a
little bit of it should I say awkward
moment with him and your nose only with
it like shooting back really talking
about the nose because I want you to be
surprised but no Ken Marino is a really
dear friend of mine so that particular
moment he makes out with my nose he
French kisses it yes and when we mmm
shot that was very serious seriously and
he he initially asked if he could do
that and it was so funny I couldn't I
had to be like it was so hard to not
laugh that was one of those times and
then I said if you're gonna do it you're
gonna have to do a choice you're gonna
have to do it twice so it's my fault
now have you found it is your first film
as director a writer and your acting in
it as well co-producing it has it been I
think you know it's been busy I think
when you wear that many hats you know
you kind of know what you're in for I
think you would be a maniac if you
thought it was gonna be easy so I think
as long as you know that it's difficult
as you're going into it and you prepare
accordingly I think then you know you're
you're set to maybe have a good time
doing it I certainly had a great time it
suited my my personality I like to multi
deaths this viral this vocal virus
that's in the film there's sexy baby
voice why do you think it's become so
rampant worth it come from I mean I
think the vocal virus the pandemic that
is the sexy baby voice that comes
heavily from America but then has seeped
into other countries
is I think it's cultural I think we've
always had vocal trends you know within
certain social groups you know but also
for instance back in the day you know in
Marilyn Monroe was the it girl you know
and she just talked breathy like then
every all the it girls decided to talk
that way so it's vocal trends are
interesting and you know they're totally
social it's totally it has to do with
them you know with with media and what's
around you you know so you know of
course I could I could point fingers on
a myriad of reality shows that have led
us to that path but you know the movie
does that anyway so what do you think
will be off to the sexy baby voice and
what's next for you after this film I
don't know what the next voice vocal
trend is I hope to change a lot of girls
with this film I hope I inspire them to
shed because these are smart I mean the
majority of the people who are infected
with the lake anyway it says saying like
I think you're really nice like that is
not acceptable
and these people might be smart people
but they are making themselves look
stupid okay I said it and then next up
I'm doing I'm doing a movie I'm an actor
for hire on another movie and I'm
writing my next feature so that's really
fun
you